okay we'll end on a question of
probability what number do you assign
that those blurry objects are
indeed aliens or something out of this
world let's just
say that there's something
extraterrestrial yeah uh I would say uh
I'm not a probability guy but I would
say
uh less
than
I would
say less than one 100,000 of
1% okay so okay and where do I get that
number um there's
surely a millions of
sightings of these things and I don't
I'm not convinced that any of them are
aliens and so my percent has to be lower
than that right so I'm actually coming
up calculating what number this would be
so I have to be lower than all the
sightings that have been reported and
all because I don't I don't think any of
those are aliens I find it highly
unlikely that they are I should say and
so is it one 100,000th of 1% so that's
um one out of 10 million chance it's
extraterrestrial so what would convince
you that it was extraterrestrial you
show Al bring out the alien bring out
the space put it in Town Square okay
have people high resolution I I can give
a whole list of things I can give an
entire list oh by the way video because
because AI can make deep fake video It's
Gonna video of aliens we will be will be
a starting point but not an ending point
as evidence for aliens just because of
the capacity to make a deep fake and
that we have Hollywood you know over on
the west coast so I would um I I would
say artifacts of alien manufactur yes or
the alien itself yeah yeah so then that
means that if I was to say hey Neil you
put up
$100,000 okay I will I will put up $10
because then that means you have drastic
drastic drastic odds in your favor if
it's 100th of 1% then my $10 to your $1
100,000
100,000th of I no yeah my numbers are
yeah yeah it's still it's still steep
it's still you're in the right Zone yes
okay you're getting a 10 to one if not
1,000 to one return so if I was to put
up $50 I'll say I'll put up $50 over the
next 15 years to your
$100,000 that should be a bet that
you're like I will sign it right now
let's do it brother that would mean if
we find Ali if wait wait wait
wait you want want me to bet against
future I'm betting against what we've
already seen that these are different
things okay fine then what we've seen
gets revealed to be aliens okay yeah so
that's where my statistic comes from the
chance is that so now so now you want
100,000 to 50,000 to 50 sure you say so
that would mean that if it's aliens I
give you say 100,000 to 50 but okay that
means if it's aliens I give you $100,000
yes if it's not aliens you give me $50
yes and that should still be wildly
wildly in your favor yeah but I I don't
I don't bet money I don't bet it's not
what I do do you know that the American
physical Society had a meeting in Las
Vegas sorry they were gonna meet in San
Diego but there's a hotel snafu this is
the the world's physicist the country's
physicist so MGM Grand said we'll take
you the MGM uh Marina hotel it was at
the time in the 80s and so they all go
to Vegas 3,000 4,000 physicists at the
end of the week there was a newspaper
headline physicists in town lowest
Casino take
ever just don't bet when you know
statistics but you're saying I should
bet because it's in my favor that's
drastically a thousand times in your
favor yeah I I don't put money on it I'm
not a money guy in that way all right
Neil Neil what are you working on next
where can how about this why don't we
make this if you want to do this
officially how about this
um how about this just because it's it's
all in fun right so should we shouldn't
change each other's Lifestyle on the bed
so how about this is it within the next
10 years something that has already been
cited show turns out to be alien okay
I'll give you $100
if it's not you give me a penny how
about that oh all right but with
inflation it's a ratio what are you
talking about it's a ra it's a ratio
okay so my penny with inflation then and
you're 100 with inflation no it's just a
ratio that's all it's capturing here
inflation keeps the same ratio what
What's the diff I mean it's a ratio bet
$100 to a penny that's a ratio of 10,000
correct yeah that's 10 no no is that
right 100,00 no that's 10,000 100 times
100 it's 10,000 right $100 is 10,000
times more than a penny yeah
okay I'll give you a penny if there's
actual aliens and that knowledge would
be way greater than a Penny's worth of
course you mean you'll give me a 100 but
yeah yeah no no sorry sorry I'd give you
a 100 no no no i' give you 100 you give
me a penny yes I S I said it backwards
yes there you go okay within how much
time within 10 years and we have to
allow like it has to be asterisk with
that something new may be revealed and
we can always bicker and say yeah but
that's totally new but then several
people be like no it has to be about
something that's already been spotted it
has to be about the history of all
observations of crazy things in the sky
all right whatever we'll work out the
details our lawyers will speak to each
other the lawyers cost more than the
value of this bag
right to be clear the Crux of the matter
isn't an endorsement of the existence of
aliens or UFOs rather it's pointing out
the in congruity of declaring
probabilities only to retract when one
stake is implicated if you enjoyed that
clip then the full podcast is out right
now you can click around here enjoy
subscribe to theories of everything to
get notified of upcoming podcasts as
there are new full length podcasts every
week on the topics of mathematics
physics Consciousness Free Will and
AI